-We were just talking
about Medicare,
and you actually needed
some medical attention yoursel
a few weeks ago.
Tell me a little bit about that.
-I was in Las Vegas.
We had an event,
and for the first time
in my life, I had to sit down.
I was just feeling
very, very tired,
and then I felt this pain
in my chest.
Got back -- We left the even
and got in the car,
and we knew something was wrong.
We went to an urgent care plac
right near the hotel,
and they said,
"You're having a heart attack.
We got to a hospital
very, very quickly.
And the care there was great
The doctors were great.
And I had two stents put in,
because it turned out that one
of my arteries was blocked up.
It was a procedure, I guess,
done about a million
times a year,
and I was out of the hospita
in 2 1/2 days,
and I've felt better ever since.
So we've been back
on the campaign trail,
knock on wood...
-Yeah, absolutely.
-...full-time
for the last couple of weeks
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you --
In general, are you a pretty
healthy guy, or not really
-That was what is amazing.
I mean, I -- Thank God,
I have been incredibly healthy
When I was a kid,
I was a long-distance runner
I was a good athlete.
So when they told me
I had a heart attack,
I literally
could not believe it,
because, you know, I have ha
so much endurance
and strength throughout
my whole body.
But, you know, in retrospect
and maybe this is a messag
I want to convey,
listen to some of the symptoms
that were taking place.
I was getting tireder
than I usually was.
-Yeah.
-So...
-Is it stress?
Are we all too stressed out?
I feel like you read
in the papers today,
everyone is so stressed out.
People who live in my building
are so stressed out.
Everyone I run into
in the streets, stressed out
-We are stressed out.
-Yeah.
-People are, for a variety
of reason, political reasons
people are worried
about their kids.
People are worried about
the environment.
People are worried
about money.
And yeah, we do live in --
People work
incredibly long hours.
I don't know if you know. We
work some of the longest hours
of any people in the world
So stress is a huge, huge issue.
-Did your wife say anythin
to you after the heart attack?
Did she say, "Hey, Bernie,
maybe let's rethink --"
-Well, she --
She was in Vermont,
and I was in Las Vegas.
She didn't sleep all that night.
She got onto the first plane
that she possibly could
and got to Las Vegas
as soon as she could.
She has hardly left me
out of her sight since.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Well, I saw you --
You definitely came back
pretty quickly,
'cause we have --
We have a clip of you
on the basketball court
just last week.
And this is for real.
Take a look at this thing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, that's a long baske
though, right?
-Yes.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God. Now --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You think you can do that agai
while we continue the interview?
-Why not?
-Let's do it, buddy. Come on
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
Now, this -- This is
a free-throw challenge.
I'm gonna ask you some questions
while shooting,
and then you will have
to answer them while shooting.
-While shooting.
-Okay, yeah.
Should I go first,
maybe see if you beat me?
-There you go.
-I'm not that good, actually
Alright, good.
[ Audience "aw"s ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright. Well, now you're
getting serious about --
-Yeah, yeah.
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
[ Audience "aw"s ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, before we continue -
Wait, hold on a second.
Before we continue,
out of any of the candidates
who would be your --
Do you have any VP picks?
-There's some great people
out there,
but it's a little bit premature.
First of all, I'm going
to have to win the nomination.
-Okay. Alright. Okay.
-You got me all excited
about playing basketball.
[ Laughter ]
-Here, you can go back there
Do you think --
You already beat me, right
[ Laughter ]
Let me see if I get one shot
-There you go.
-Alright, I got one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience "aw"s ]
♪♪♪♪
-Do you think that you hav
a real shot at this?
-Do we have a real shot?
Yes, we do.
I think --
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-One more. Shoot one more.
-Alright.
-Finally, this time next year,
will you be President
of the United States?
-Why not?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aw. Come on.
Don't dunk it, please.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Senator Bernie Sanders,
everybody!
Katherine Langford joins u
after the break! Stick around!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both speak indistinctly